há alguns anos eu me encontrava muito
aflito para saber qual seria o primeiro
longa metragem já tinha tido várias
idéias pensar em conceitos e propostas
mas nada e tocavam me fazer crer que
tinha algo precioso nas mãos
eu acredito para você realizar um filme
você precisa está completamente
apaixonado necessária conexão mais
profunda como a jornada onde você escuta
o chamado embarcam na trajetória sem
saber exatamente onde isso vai dar
eu vi essas buscas até o dia que eu
decidi fazer uma viagem pelo melhor
amigo dele era mario ea gente imaginou
ir para o deserto do atacama muito
rapidamente a gente ficou empolgado com
essa ideia começa a fazer pesquisas e
fotos naquele mesmo instante eu senti um
estalo que eu queria fazer um filme
sobre isso que eu queria filmar mário
indo para o deserto do atacama foi algo
mágico mais clichê que possa parecer
eu não sabia exatamente como seria esse
filme ou como iria filmar um deserto
mas eu tinha certeza de que iria fazer
esse filme e isso é o mais importante
eu pensei em fazer esse filme porque me
admirava a forma como mario lidava com a
vida
ele tinha criança há quatro anos já
tinha superado todos os prognósticos
médicos não havia mais nada que ele
pudesse fazer e é interessante porque eu
jamais via mário reclamar se queixar ou
se lamentar
ao contrário mas estava sempre alegres
diâmetro entusiasmado
aquele comportamento de mário me
ensinava muito sobre a importância de
viver o momento presente e aceitar as
coisas como elas são
é interessante porque de maneira geral a
gente sempre reclama quando alguma coisa
foge da nossa zona de conforto a gente
reclama e mário era um completamente
diferente disso
eu acredito que os pacientes terminam
terminais eles desenvolvem a sabedoria
de lidar com a permanência até porque
tudo na vida em permanente
talvez porque eles não sabem o quanto
eles vão viver
eles apreciam cada instante genuinamente
aquele comportamento de maria ensinava
muito então logo depois eu comecei a
escrever um roteiro enquanto a escrever
esse roteiro mário pensava na trajetória
da viagem
assim as rotas das cidades
a gente comprou as passagens eu chamei
um amigo nosso para fazer o som direto
do filme nesse processo eu pedi pra
mário registrar o seu cotidiano das
coisas que era importante para ele e sua
família o seu dia a dia ea idéia é que
ele iria levar esses registros
autobiográficos o deserto como forma de
levar sua memória
estava tudo muito bem sendo que maio
teve uma crise de saúde
essa crise veio a falecer poucos dias
antes da viagem
é algo muito impactante para mim eu
nunca tinha lutado com a moto
aqui era muito forte mas que tivesse
explicações racionais aquela sensação de
ruptura era muito maior
o conceito é muito pequeno e obviamente
eu pensei que tudo tinha naufragado
principalmente o filme já que o mar é o
personagem se alguns meses se passaram e
como se eu tivesse tranquila sentia que
carregava um vazio até que é sobrinho do
marido me ligou perguntando se eu queria
os vídeos que estava no computador dele
os registos autobiográfico que estava
fazendo para levar o deserto
eu nem me lembrava mais esses vídeos
esquecido diz completamente e foi
surpreendente me deparar com os últimos
registros de marca e venda
esses registros não chamaram muita
atenção nisso ele tem uma mergulhando no
mar e adorava mergulhar
acho que ele mais gostava de fazer
é impressionante pensar na motivação
dele fazer esse registro esse mesmo ele
fluindo dentro do mar
leve e feliz área completamente entregue
de braços abertos para viver outras
vezes que me chama muito atenção ele fez
um prédio com ele esse mar e agradece a
vida que ele tinha e faz referência ao
sol
afinal esse é o último registro da vida
de marina
em todo esse amor e dedicação ea forma
como ele estava se expondo e se
entregando o filme tinha certeza que eu
tinha que concluiu que a gente tinha
iniciado
eu tinha que terminar esse filme que eu
tinha que viajar com o deserto do
atacama
logo em seguida me veio a idéia de que
ele iria então o deserto para superar a
morte do mário e para levá-lo
simbolicamente nosso mirim o lugar de
mário no roteiro
aquilo era completamente desafiador para
mim eu jamais imaginei ser personagem de
um filme mas pensei ficar na frente das
câmeras inclusive o marido tentava mexer
maior permitir essa coragem que o marido
estava se entregando e fazia querer que
eu não podia ter mesmo que enfrente eu
tinha que fazer esse filme eu partir
seguindo a mesma trajetória e o mesmo
roteiro original parte sem saber
exatamente o que é viver eu queria
sentir na certeza de que eu tinha que
realizar isso
a rota que mário penz ou a gente saía de
recife frio até santa cruz de la sierra
na bolívia
de avião depois de ônibus ante o assunto
enquanto se une em ibiúna a gente
alugava um jipe atravessava a fronteira
da bolívia com o chile até chegar ao
deserto do atacama
eram 6 mil 300 quilômetros
vem comigo os vídeos autobiográficos do
mário mas jamais imaginei que é uma
viagem tão longa e exaustiva como foi
mas eu posso garantir também que uma das
coisas mais incríveis e superintendência
minha vida
uma das coisas mais interessantes nessa
viagem que ao longo desse percurso eu
conheci algumas pessoas desses encontros
são geradas as entrevistas do filme o
incrível quanto aprendi com essas
pessoas mais simples que elas fossem
elas tinham tanta sabedoria e tanto amor
em falar dos seus amigos do que era
importante em suas vidas
também no final elas vão me agradecer me
abraçavam e dizem que incrível que você
me fez lembrar muito importante seguir
viagem também fortalecer e cumprir uma
missão
quando eu cheguei no deserto do atacama
e levei meu amigo tinha pais
indescritível algo muito difícil de
traduzir
eu sabia que tinha realizado a jornada
pessoal que jamais seria a mesma pessoa
depois disso tive a certeza que tudo que
aquilo que eu tinha vivido e fazer
entender melhor nada nessa vida
em seguida voltei para recife mas ainda
teve uma outra grande missão eu
precisava finalizar o filme e distribuir
nos cinemas
isso é outra grande é porque tinha
muitas horas de imagem que tinha muitos
elementos possíveis eu precisava definir
que tipo de abordagem estrutura eu
queria entregá-lo documentário precisava
definir o que eu queria como eu queria
comunicar esse filme
foram nove meses de montagem onde ele
refletindo sobre o que teria motivado
tudo isso
o objetivo para quem é esse filme pra
mim é arrumar nossos amigos de todas as
questões
eu tinha um filme do que abbas
kiarostami agostinho em que ele faz uma
homenagem ao cinema
peres que choram a ver um filme
ao ver isso me lembrei do poder do
cinema de emocionar as pessoas e também
me lembrei o que que isso era foi o que
sempre me motivou a fazer cinema
possibilitar que os filmes independence
que tipo de proposta mobilizar essas
pessoas com a transformação íntima e
humana era muito livre e humano
principalmente não tinha medo de
expressar seus sentimentos
esse é o caminho que o filme deveria
seguir
acho que era isso e gostaria de inspirar
as pessoas em meu papel era transformar
o que eu sentia como seu amigo e me
preparando nossa morte com uma expressão
cinematográfica um filme que fosse um
simples humano e sobretudo pudesse
emocionar as pessoas é muito
interessante que sem que jamais
planejasse também realizando meu
primeiro longa metragem a forma
extremamente pessoal imprevisível
esse filme se não o tempo todo que não
tinha controle nenhum sobre nada
afinal não temos controle nenhum sobre
nada nessa vida como também me ensinou
que talvez nosso maior desafio seja
apenas deixar fluir aceitar as coisas
como elas são
eu estava no deserto e lembrei muito do
mar mergulhando feliz
lembrei do clube do fácil dele pelo mapa
os naufrágios estava realizando um sonho
e algo muito forte e fazer crer que ele
estava comigo estava se divertindo
também pensei que não existe uma
separação entre a vida ea morte ou entre
o deserto e essa foi a forma que
encontrei de levar meu amigo
simbolicamente
após um tempo pessoas chegou pra mim e
me agradeceu profundamente
ela disse que tinha se emocionado muito
com o filme que possa assim após
assistindo ela ligou do seu pai e disse
que o amava
eu fiquei muito feliz porque sente que o
filme tinha cumprido o seu papel
acho que nada é mais importante do que
despertar o amor uma pessoa
talvez essa seja a maior de todas as
jornadas eu queria terminar essa
palestra fazendo três perguntas pra
vocês vocês descobrirem que um amigo de
vocês está com a doença terminal que
vocês fariam se vocês descobrirem que
vocês estão com a doença terminal que
vocês fariam
será que é necessário realizar aquilo
que vocês pensaram neste momento a
descoberta de uma doença terminal
a descoberta em algum momento vocês vão
se deparar com a morte
a vida acontece agora no momento
presente
tome uma decisão efetiva e amorosa para
suas vidas que nada é mais importante do
que o amor eo afeto hoje
agora sempre muito obrigado